divers guibert des slogans contre la
politique du gouvernement deuxième coup
de force des syndicats à une semaine
près et la mobilisation ne faiblit pas
ils étaient au moins 3000 dans la rue
des syndicalistes et sympathisants unis
contre la réforme des retraites
nous voulons pas celles qui viennent
après une retraite réduite au moins que
car c'est sûr qu'après l'effondrement
je suis pas tellement concernés par
cette des fonds mais là je n'ai jamais
je n'ai peut-être pas là vous voir ça
dans le cortège des personnels
hospitaliers aux côtés des enseignants
en majorité la profession est vent
debout
déjà à toulouse par les précédentes
réformes ont seront certainement les
plus grands perdants
ainsi nous acceptons cette semaine cette
réforme parce que chez les enseignants
si on accepte le système qui est proposé
est bien il peut prendre en compte
l'ensemble de la carrière
nous avons des salaires très bas en
débutant avec des salaires très bas
nous débutons un peu plus de 1000 euros
nous débutons aussi très table dans la
fonction puisque nous avons des études
longues et finalement
lorsqu'on prend pas encore décidée en
émoi eh bien on aura finalement une
pension très faible les contours de la
réforme sont déjà plus ou moins dessiné
à la place des trimestres cotisés il
faudra compter en fonction de points
acquis un système inégalée faussée selon
les syndicats de même atteint comme par
magie comme par miracle on va pouvoir
nous donner un projet bien ficelé avec
les arbitrages et tous nous on n'y croit
pas et pour nous cet enfumage
pour force ouvrière j'assume lecteurs
nous pas quand même aux libéraux c'est
le retrait du projet gouvernemental
les syndicats sont suspendus à la
présentation du projet de réforme demain
par le premier ministre